[Musique]
le s salon du livre d'histoire de
versailles se tiendra les 17 et 18
novembre je reçois donc que les manuels
de crépy y bonsoir maire adjointe à la
culture de la ville ainsi avec une des
auteures historienne qui sera présente
cécile coutin alors c'est un rendez vous
qui s'est imposée véritablement depuis
sa création c'était 2008
oui est ce que fait cinq ans donc c'est
la cinquième édition on en est très
content est ce que c'était est ce que le
but est resté le même pas ce que c'était
en 2008 l'objectif était en 2008
véritablement de d'ouvrir plus grand
nombre d'intéressés les gens sur ce
genre un petit peu particulier à part du
livre d'histoire pour parler de
l'histoire est ce que c'est toujours le
même but que vous recherchez alors c'est
toujours le même but donc avec toujours
le une entrée libre
qui est vraiment volontaire et
politiquement volontaire avec françois
de mazières maire de versailles et en
association avec etienne de montéty de
faire donc un qui soit ouvert à
tous nous avons ouvert l'année dernière
un grand espace jeunesse une tante
jeunesse qui puisse accueillir le
maximum de monde
nous avons cette année aussi d'autres
espaces qui accueille les éventuels
lecteurs puisque nous avons pu faire
accéder aux séries ouvrir en fait
l'atelier numérique un nouvel espace à
versailles et des visites sont
organisées aussi à la bibliothèque donc
des conférences ont lieu aussi à
l'université interâges à proximité de la
mairie de versailles et dans la mairie
de versailles
on voit les images de l'édition
précédente issu de votre site internet
qui relaie cette information pour ce 5e
salon du livre d'histoire c'était une
évidente de l'organiser sur versailles
justement alors le livre d'histoire
d'abord la thématique histoire
certainement et aussi de livres puisque
les versaillais et aux alentours et ici
nous sommes dans les yvelines sont
certainement très intéressés par la
lecture par l'histoire et effectivement
ça intéresse que ce soit les jeunes les
moins jeunes et beaucoup de monde c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
important effectivement tous les styles
sont présents monographie biographie et
ses bandes dessinées et les allemands ya
des animations pour les plus jeunes on
aura l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure cécile coûtant vous vous
présentez tromper l'ennemi l'invention
du camouflage moderne pendant la grande
guerre
parlez nous de ce sujet pourquoi ce
choix de traiter la section camouflage
de l'armée française qui a été créé je
me suis renseigné quatre autres 1915
oui
c'est ma carrière qui m'a amené à
m'intéresser à ce sujet j'ai d'abord été
nommé comme conservateur au musée
d'histoire contemporaine qui est la
collection iconographique de la
bibliothèque de documentation
internationale contemporaine
la bibliothèque est un en terre et le
musée se trouvait encore à l'époque où
j'ai été nommé donc en décembre 1972 au
château de vincennes et ma première
mission a été de déménager le musée et
par suite d'un échange de locaux entre
le ministère de la défense et les
universités ce musée est arrivé à
l'hôtel national des invalides
donc entre le musée de l'armée et le
musée des plans reliefs
cela m'a valu de faire l'inventaire des
collections du musée et j'ai découvert
je le savais un peu bien sûr avant
d'accepter ce poste mais j'ai découvert
que ce n'était pas du tout un musée
militaire mais un musée qui présente les
oeuvres qui sont le regard des artistes
sur les grands événements du 20e siècle
et les collections étaient
particulièrement riche et le sont
toujours sur la première guerre mondiale
et j'ai découvert tous ces témoignages
laissés par les artistes qui m'ont paru
extrêmement bouleversant très émouvant
plus fort que des photographies et il
faut dire aussi que peu de soldats
disposer d'appareils photo et que ceux
qui avaient un bon coup de crayon
n'hésitez pas à emporter des calepins et
a dessiné ce qu'il voyait sur le front
ou au repos
il ya 3 600 documents dans votre ouvrage
ça oui oui mais le musée évidemment
enfin tout ne vient pas de ce musée mais
ce musée est extrêmement riche
effectivement puisque je crois qu'on
peut compter environ 50 mille oeuvres
originales voyez c'est assez assez
important sur l'ensemble du xxème siècle
bien sûr alors le camouflage
en fait il est né très très tôt très tôt
pendant la guerre ce sont quelques
artistes qui se trouvait dans le même
dans le même secteur et dans
dans le domaine de l'artillerie au fort
de domgermain à toul l'un qui était un
personnage assez connu à ses célèbres
qui était un grand professeur de l'école
des beaux-arts à paris et un autre qui
est resté un peu plus dans l'ombre mais
qui est probablement le véritable
inventeur qui était je n'ai pas dit le
nom du premier s'était vite
victor guirande cvo là et le second
louis guingo était un peintre décorateur
il travaillait notamment beaucoup pour
le théâtre il était originaire de nancy
et c'est lui qui a imaginé la première
veste de camouflage qui n'a pas eu
l'heur de plaire à l'armée ou enfin au
service des inventions de l'armée et
donc qui n'a pas été créée à cette
période là c'est plutôt dans
l'entre-deux-guerres qu'on va commencer
à utiliser ce type de tissu qu'on a
quand même créé pendant la première
guerre mondiale mais qu'on a utilisé
pour d'autres missions si vous voulez
d'autres fonctions donc ces artistes se
rendre compte très vite que quand leurs
batteries se met à tirer les canons
brille au soleil et les observateurs
allemands par avion les remarque tout de
suite et font régler le tir de leur
propre artillerie et évidemment cela
occasionne des blessés des morts donc
l'invention le camoufle halter en
tournant un petit peu dans l'embarras
d'ailleurs en fait très vite en
septembre 1914 vraiment dès le début est
immédiatement ces artistes vont imaginer
de peindre des toiles aux couleurs de la
terre enfin en couleurs du paysage
environnant d'en recouvrir les batteries
et de faire porter aux servants de ses
pièces des blues également dans des
teintes vertes
beige marron effectivement ils font
survolé les emplacements par un leurs
amis aviateurs qui dit qu'il ne repère
rien du tout et vous qu on laisse couler
ça non vois tu rejoignes dans cet
ouvrage de tromper l'ennemi l'invention
du camouflage moderne pendant la grande
guerre quel est votre objectif justement
sur ce sur ce salon c'est de faire
passer tout ce savoir de weeds et
connaissez le sujet sur le bout des
doigts oui voilà mais en fait
curieusement ce camouflage a été inventé
par les français et qui l'ont ensuite
enseigné aux belges aux anglais aux
italiens et aux américains certains ont
été plus forts dans certains domaines et
il ya eu des allers-retours et chacun
s'est enrichi de l'autre si vous voulez
mais curieusement s'il ya des livres en
langue anglaise
humble saxon il n'y avait aucun livre en
langue française alors bien sûr il ya
des articles il y à des catalogues
d'exposition c'est un sujet qui ressort
périodiquement mais conquis retombe
souvent dans l'oubli donc j'espère que
mon livre va combler un manque d'intérêt
mais c'est ça l'objectif du salon est
également de présenter des des ouvrages
qui sont sur des thèmes qui sont parfois
méconnu parce que des livres qui parlent
de l'histoire il y en a beaucoup il ya
certains sujets on pense même avoir fait
le tour comme la grande guerre par
exemple mais ce n'est pas le cas alors
effectivement notre objectif est de
présenter ces sujets là effectivement
mais aussi le l'objectif de ce salon du
livre d'histoire et de présenter des
ouvrages qui ont été publiés dans
l'année donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement récent donc c'est vraiment
de l'actualité sur l'histoire ce qui
paraît peut-être curieux d'ailleurs mais
effectivement il ya toujours beaucoup de
choses qui sont à renouveler à
redécouvrir
donc on a aussi pas mal de tête
d'affiche des personnalités que vous
pouvez rencontrer qui sont très érudit
très pointu sur leur sujet
quelques têtes d'affiché donc
musique et maïté halo paris donc tifra
qui fera l'ouverture samedi à 14 heures
donc à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
pour le salon par le passé vous avez u11
de coke est venue également lorànt
deutsch aussi des personnalités cette
année ce sera stéphane bern il faut des
personnalités pour un salon de ce genre
c'est venus de tous les horizons en plus
je pense que c'est important pour le
public aussi de pouvoir rencontrer des
auteurs peut-être moins connus très
pointu mais qui ont vraiment une pierre
a ajouté dans l'histoire des auteurs qui
sont extrêmement connu et qui permettent
aussi de rencontrer leur public c'est
quand même très important et avec le
député maire françois de mazières
c'était vraiment notre objectif de
pouvoir faire une rencontre très grand
public voilà c'était vraiment cet
objectif et quel regard vous portez
justement sur ce festival est la
présence de stéphane bern par exemple de
lorànt deutsch des personnes qui fait
qu'ils parlent de l'histoire aussi au
quotidien mais chacun en venant
d'horizons très différents
quel regard vous portez de sur ses
personnages par exemple sur leurs façons
de faire de l'histoire
je n'ai pas forcément lui tous les
ouvrages mais je sais que c'est toujours
un grand plaisir pour moi de devenir à
ce salon du livre je viens depuis le
début et j'avais même espérer l'année
dernière pouvoir y faire venir un ami
qui venait de sortir un livre mais je
n'avais pas compris que c'était à
l'éditeur de faire la démarche
bon donc pour mon propre livre cette
année le créneau bien fait d'explorer le
présenter cette année qu'elle ait un
petit peu l'aura du festival vous voulez
le développer encore plus ses 8000
visiteurs l'an dernier
alors c'est beaucoup de visiteurs c'est
une aura effectivement importante je
pense surtout que c'est important de
toucher un public le plus varié possible
qu'ils puissent à la fois découvrir
l'histoire les auteurs nous travaillons
aussi avec les libraires de versailles
qui ont vraiment si ce relais sein de la
ville et c'est vraiment important je
pense qu'on fasse ce travail et les
acteurs locaux je parlais des
bibliothèques et laura c'est aussi de
pouvoir faire découvrir nos institutions
ce qui existe à versailles et surtout
l'histoire et le livre d'histoire donc
voilà je pense que c'est vraiment
important pour l'ensemble du public donc
le plus l'aura sera importante plus
mieux ceci d'intéresser les plus jeunes
aussi ont droit
il ya des animations qui sont organisées
il y en a quelques unes donc sur sur le
salon des ateliers par exemple pour
intéresser à l'histoire en plus jeunes
voilà des ateliers avec aussi une petite
animation qui intéressera les jeunes et
les moins jeunes c'est l'arrivée en
véhicules anciens des auteurs que vous
avez peut-être pu constater et bah vous
souligner le fait qu'il y à des ateliers
pour les plus jeunes donc on a plusieurs
types d'ateliers avec des animations
pour les plus jeunes et ça vraiment un
succès important et c'est vraiment
important pour nous de favoriser la
lecture publique on a d'autres
événements le long de l'année pour
favoriser la lecture et ça fait partie
de notre politique culturelle cette
année le travail a été mené auprès des
collégiens également exactement vous
êtes il ya eu des conférences qui ont
été organisées la du concert avec le
conseil général
c'est très important de tous les
partenaires sont associés autour de cet
événement le salon se déroule les 17 et
18 novembre à versailles
hôtel de ville programme complet en
ligne n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
site internet de la municipalité mis en
place merci à toutes les deux être venu
donc sur ce plateau et l'entrée est
gratuite
on leur précise on l'a dit au tout début
mais on leur précise on marche juste une
pause à présent direction coignard ceux
qui fréquentent la zone commerciale du
dit du forum vont avoir des surprises
dans les prochaines années presque à
l'abandon depuis le départ est d'une
grande enseigne de bricolage elle va
faire peau neuve les explications
d'alice gastines et de patrick jacques
de dixmude
il aura fallu plus de quatre ans pour
que ce centre commercial de coignières
fasse peau neuve
construit en 1987 avec l'implantation de
castorama le forum voit son attractivité
décliner quand l'enseigne des ménages
aux portes de chevreuse mais reste
propriétaire du foncier
nous avons eu à cette époque
l'envahissement du secteur par des gens
du voyage cet envahissement a duré près
de deux mois
une situation qui aurait dissuadé
truffaut de s'installer au forum ne
restait plus que des 4 ou sur les rangs
pas suffisant pour lancer des travaux de
rénovation malgré l'autorisation
délivrée par la commission
départementale d'aménagement commercial
en 2011 le nombre d'enseignants qui est
atteint mais de recours successifs
déposée par un riverain freine le projet
finalement le problème juridique et
régler la rénovation peut alors
reprendre
toujours semer d'embûches il faut il
faut franchir toutes les étapes obtenir
d'avoir la cdac ensuite eu le permis
donc on a tous à trop de temps et puis
de les préparer à l'idée auprès des
enseignes dans la période actuelle sont
pas tout enclin à se développer
on va dire récurrentes aurait dû
rechercher des fichiers
le promoteur indépendant sopic
spécialisé dans l'urbanisme commercial a
investi 20 millions d'euros dans le
projet quatorze mille mètres carrés de
terrain vont être totalement repensé
avec la construction d'un bâtiment haute
qualité environnementale niveau emploi
le nouveau forum devrait permettre une
centaine d'embauchés mais aussi de
redynamiser le secteur et c'est
important également pour l'image de la
commune nous avons un secteur en entrée
de ville qui est actuellement je dirais
en grande difficulté qui a besoin d'être
qualifiés qui a besoin d'être
réhabilités de rénover d'être rénovée et
donc ça pour la commune c'est très
important que cette opération folleville
la zone de chalandise représente 360
mille habitants date prévue de fin des
travaux juin 2013 devrait suivre
l'ouverture des enseignes à la rentrée
de septembre quatre ont déjà signé